[Musik]
bayern landkreis dingolfing ich warte
auf den bus kommt nicht kommt heute gar
nicht mehr denn der landkreis ist spitze
dem kaum vorhandenen öffentlichen
nahverkehr reform im bus sie meinen weil
sie eine umgebung eh nix gibt eben ich
habe selbst mal versucht ich wohne im
dorf außerhalb
statt motto bus zu benutzen hätte ideale
voraussetzungen gehabt als lehrer weil
die schülerbusse da genau gepasst hätten
aber habe dann festgestellt dass er mit
dem radl eigentlich doppelt so schnell
bin und sich in einem voll besetzten
schulbus reinzuquetschen ist nicht
gerade angenehm sie hassen kinder nein
verlassen können alle meinen nein
gegenteil
die zeit scheint reif für meine
geschäftsidee den individuellen city
express kurz die 10
ich habe ihn dabei ok und da steht ja
wunderbar die vierzügigkeit ja ich nehme
sie jetzt gleich mit
steigen sie ein es ist die märkte
zurückkehrt
willkommen an bord des ece welcome on
board auf der einzigen zurückbleiben
bitte
danke schön herr lieber schafft da ich
fahre zum ca eine tolle die förderung
bis zu langsam aber ist passt warum ist
das in mir auch bergauf gesagt habt
ja
[Applaus]
ganz los sie sind ein super der reifen
sind wir also jetzt über sie jetzt
wieder draußen alles klar nec station
imbisstheke die fahrgäste wir haben eine
störung im betriebsablauf
und weiter geht's noch weiter ja sie
wollen doch noch wollen noch zu zäh oder
nicht
[Gelächter]
natürlich ist der gti nicht so schnell
wie der legendäre dingo in der
dingolfinger stadtbus mit dem kommt man
aber nicht weit deswegen ist die nutzung
er so mediums fahren sie gern mal mit
dem dingo mit diesem bus schon ja
und sie
über den lustigen namen hat sich der
dingolfinger auch nicht wirklich
gedanken gemacht bingo ist ja dieser
bluthund dieser blut und der er auch
kinder entführt also damals in den 80ern
in australien hat ein kind mitgenommen
naja nimmt kinder mit aber die steigen
heute und wieder aus wissen sie was
haben sie schon mal kinder einsteigen
sehen und auch in der form und ingo und
die steigen soviel ich weiss auch wieder
aus ich treffe den landrat und ich hab
da so eine ahnung warum der pnv gier
nicht funktioniert schlecht
spnv
und größtes bmw-werk europa aus ich bin
kein sherlock holmes aber gibt es dann
zu sagen
es gibt einen zusammenhang dass bei uns
der pnv nicht so angenommen wird weil
bmw alle mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter mit den bussen zu ihrem
arbeitsplatz fährt ob der bmw boss aber
auch den gleichen grund vor bietet die
man die ce bezweifle ich wir haben
französische wochen genießen sie ein
frisches mon chéri
ist im preis inbegriffen
praktische wie hat es ihnen gefallen der
super-g hat gut gefallen waren mal
interessant werden biete ich ihnen noch
an die die lutz card 25 oder die nutzer
künftig die könnte ich noch anbieten
gelten aber nur werktags von 8.30 bis
11.30 und nur wenn sie noch jemand
anderen mitnehmen der ebenfalls einen
oscar hat 25 oder 50 und nur in den
monaten die mit ihr anfangen
mission dingolfing erfolgreich ich mache
mich auch und vielleicht fahren dann
bald im ganzen land ics und bringen
glückliche menschen an viele orte oder
schnell von dort weg
hallo leute ich bin der heute-show
[Musik]
hersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß
und 70 - wollt dann abonniert jetzt den
kanal
was zur hölle ist mine hersteller
[Musik]